- À 24 ans, elle partage sa vie
amoureuse avec son conjoint
à Chicoutimi. Lundi, elle s'est
tournée vers un pharmacien
lorsqu'elle a craint
une grossesse non désirée.
- J'avais un peu la boule dans
l'estomac, je me sentais mal,
je me sentais vraiment jugée.
- Au Jean Coutu, le pharmacien a
plaidé sa conscience religieuse
pour lui refuser
la contraception orale
d'urgence, aussi appelée
la "pilule du lendemain".
- Je ne pense pas que c'est au
pharmacien de nous faire sentir
comme ça, c'est nos décisions.
C'est à moi de prendre cette
décision-là, ce n'est pas à lui.
C'est mon corps à moi.
SYLVIE PEDNEAULT, directrice
générale, SOS Grossesse
- Comment je me sens?
Je suis outrée, en fait!
- Une brèche préoccupante
pour la santé reproductive
des femmes, parcquque
la contraception d'urgence
doit être prise dans un délai
de 12 à 72 heures après
une relation sexuelle.
- La question qui nous vntnt
c'est : jusqu'où va
l'objectivité de conscience?
Puis comment se fait-il que
des valeurs religieuses aient
préséance sur le librehohoix
d'autrui?
GISÈLE DALLAIRE,Table concert.
groupes de femmes S. Lac-St-Jean
- Ce pharmacien-là, est-ce qu'il
fait la même chose quand
des patients arrivent,
ont besoin de traitements
de VIH, besoin de traitements
contre des ITS? T'sais, je
trouve ça vraiment déplorable.
- La liberté de conscience,
au niveau de la Charte.
- Les professionnels de la
santé, dont les pharmaciens,
peuvent bel et bien refuser
d'octroyer des soins en vertu de
la Charte des droits et libertés
de la personne.
PATRICK MARTIN MÉNARD
avocat en droit de la santé
- C'est surtout au niveau
des médecins, qui refusent de
pratiquer des avortements par
exemple, ou l'aide médicale
à mourir aussi.
- Ces objeeueurs de conscience
ont néanmoins la responsabilité
de référer adéquatement les
femmes à un autre pharmacien
pour lui assurer les soins
adéquats.
- Fondamentalement, il faut
éviter qu'on en vienne à placer
ce fardeau-là sur les épaules
d'une patiente qui a besoin
de ce traitement-là dans un
délai rapproché. Il ne faut pas
qu'on s'en lave les mains.
- Le pharmacien au Jean Coutu de
Chicoutimi a admis avoir réfusé
de donner la pilule du ldedemain
par le passé,
tout en déclinant notre
demande d'entrevue.
- T'sais, en ce moment, aux
États-Unis, ilsntnt perdu
le droit à l'avortement, puis
c'est la première fois que
je me sentais comme bloquée
de quelque part. J'étais là :
"bien voyonsononc! On est au
Québec, c'est quoi le rapport?
- Même si elle a été référée
à une pharmacie avoisinnante,
son expérience lui aura laissée
un arrière-goût amer.
- Je me suis jamais sent